one of the best things every year at e3
is the surprises the games you didn't
know we're coming and the games that
blow you away when you see them for the
very first time
one of those is horizon zero dawn from
guerrilla games and joining me on the
couch now Herman and JB guys thank you
so much for coming here and thank you so
much for debuting such an awesome
looking game thank you
it's fantastic to be here yeah is it
kind of that kind of thing of like
you've been working on this game for a
little while now and now everyone gets
to see it for the first time you can say
the word horizon and confident right and
zero dolls do you say it once to horizon
zero dawn yeah oh my god I'm going we've
been working on this game for almost
five years it's very exciting for us to
finally be here show to the rest of the
world and I mean but mine brims with so
many questions but for those who didn't
catch the reveal at Sony's press
conference I've basically sort of a post
post-apocalypse world it's like the
apocalypse happened everyone was
recovering sure but now it's it's like
the distant future to the point where
the sort of the old ones who built these
skyscrapers are myth it's exactly so we
the Cataclysm happened we're about a
thousand years on so Nature has
completely reclaimed the land and you
know that's that's where to twist this
human life is no longer the dominant
species it's now the machines that run
the show yeah I was wondering so you
guys they're machines clearly sort of
they're creatures but this is an
ecosystem that's developed and there are
carnivores and herbivores if you could
call them carnivores and herbivores I
mean you guys had to kind of puzzle out
a whole web of nature when designing
those creatures right yeah there's a
whole ecological or ecology there and
it's all very intertwined we're not
really gonna tell you basically how
older walls are interconnected and what
the exact backstory is but basically
that's one of the big mysteries about
playing the game and finding it out but
in the movie you can you could already
call out a couple of the elements where
you see the machines working together a
Loy she's taken out the little watcher
because clearly he will alert some of
the bigger more aggressive machines
uh-huh
and so you see them come together you
also see the
some of these these grazers you have the
regular herd like but also more the
alpha guys that will take you on so
there's a lot of collaboration between
the machines and then of course the
giant sort of dinosaur brontosaurus
esque ones roaming in the background
just all these questions come to mind
are those disks they get solar power you
know how do they do all this stuff and I
think that you know obviously you're not
gonna go too deep into it now but just
the way you that sort of sparks the
imagination was this something that for
you guys was really must have been just
a tremendous an act of creativity and
collaboration yeah especially from a
story for investigators weaving this
whole universe maybe where the robots
and a sort of tribal form of mankind
lived next to each other it's been
really interesting playing with us the
components and seeing how they interlock
and we yeah we haven't even seen sort of
the nobles they're referenced in the
trailer but this is just one tribe
they're all so there's a whole human
society in addition to you know the the
creatures we see and that's exactly what
this game is about all these big
questions these machines where did they
come from
why are they here how does a Loy as the
as the playable character how does she
relate to them and and she's taking us
on a journey to uncover exactly these
kind of mysteries and I think the word
we're late there is so key one of the
moments that a lot of people I talk to
about this really latched on to was when
she takes out that first creature and
says you know she's she's gentle she's
just sorry little one there's a kind of
respect shown for the creatures it's not
this normal adversarial man versus
machine from the relationship no to the
people of this Vil baby these machines
are part of nature they are a form of
nature and they've never actually known
a world without these machines so to
them maybe they don't really see the
difference between the keys and the
birds and the fish or the machines maybe
I walk the lands yes because they're
also organic creatures DC birds fly
they're not it's not all machine
creatures it's just another pillar of
this whole world and all right I could I
would I want to talk lore and the
creation of these creatures forever but
now we're in combat here and let's talk
a little bit about this you guys have
gone from killzone the series
first-person shooter you know par
excellence and now into a third-person
action game
there's shooting sort of what was your
what's your philosophy for what kind of
experience want to create for the player
in combat so clearly you see a Lloyd
being a member of a relatively primitive
tribe taking on a massive giant robotic
machine here so she said the raw power
she could never match so she will have
to be smart she will have to be agile
and that is before during and after
combat she says she's got a bow with a
lot of different types of ammo on it
she's got a rope caster to tie him down
it's all about intelligence agility and
knowledge here and in terms of combat
and obviously we're building on the
experience we've gained making Killzone
Killzone was all about tactical combat
and so is horizon so in that sense we're
kind of building on the legacy mm-hmm
and you know we're seeing the
protagonist here Adaline is on her name
hey Lloyd hey Lloyd hey Lloyd hey lore
and she's using weapons that are sort of
machine Salvage machine built but when
you talk about the human society you
guys talk about Nobles and sort of a
that sort of implies a different scale
of weaponry and of organization and of
society so that's just another part of
the world creation item and that's the
part of it baby that the tribes in this
world have very little understanding of
technology they're not at that level yet
but they do have this very high level of
technology in nature so these machines
may have their own elements we're gonna
have ammo types that are explosives or
certain weapons and a lowest type of
combat is also about being resourceful
about gathering these resources and
combining to make new weapons out of it
that you can use against the machines
yeah and let's talk about something
that's you know gathering resources
stuff that's outside of combat can you
give a little hint about what kind of
the the gameplay flow is gonna be
between combat times and calm and
exploration or anything like that
III think it's it's a little early to go
in too much depth on the RPG side of
things but in this movie you already see
a whole you see her actually harvesting
some of the elements you see in the
weaponry that there's robotic elements
machine elements already on her weapons
she uses that for her armor for her for
ammo and other things you see the
grazers there they're kind of mining the
earth
you see the canisters that she's after
so clearly these have a purpose for her
so that that's a big part of this game
it is an action open-world RPG it is an
open-world RPG ah with competitive
multiplayer added in of course we're
making a single-player game thank you
very much
fantastic and it just looks gorgeous
- I mean you guys have been working on
it for five years but in five years Tech
has changed Tech has evolved but you
guys a gorilla have always sort of been
on top
keeping your game keeping you know sort
of at the bleeding edge to the art
director yeah how do you sort of you
know art direction and then technical
execution you guys just marry those so
well yeah well you know building
Killzone has always been a very good
experience very good we love sign
fiction but this was something
completely new for us as well building
very large very lush rules it's a
completely new different challenge so
all the greenery on helping all the
artists basically went from okay I'm
really good at making metal and concrete
so now okay I'm gonna get become really
[ __ ] good at making trees and grass
and big mountains so you guys just have
nature documentaries running in the
background all day long all day lots of
but a world like this I mean this is at
a an apocalypse but then a thousand
years on try to think that through
conceptually there is obviously no
photographic reference of a world like
that so everything is being discussed by
the team and not just the arty but
predominantly also the design team it's
all it's been a lot of sussing out for
us I would imagine so and just yeah kind
of conceptualizing what kind of story
you want to tell in the world because
you're taking on you know at least the
themes that come to mind the man versus
machine the sort of technology versus
nature
you're subverting that in a big way but
so there's still there's power to be
found an identification in terms of our
natural reactions oh god the giant robot
monster must be evil but you're really
sort of playing at maybe something
that's more nuanced than that there are
a lot of big themes here life after us
what happens actually when when
humankind no longer is that dominant
species there's also the autonomy of
machines of drones that how does that
work so we're not necessarily answering
all those scientific questions in great
detail in this game but they are
the backdrop for us coming up with these
big concepts yeah I don't need to know
what you know what the exact chemistry
is of these green tanks on the back of
the grazier here but man they're there
there is a reason for all of that in the
game oh yeah yeah that guess that's
another challenge right if you're
building an entire world an entire new
place you're conceptualizing you also
have to have some focus otherwise you're
never going to develop a game you got to
sort of pare down the things that are
important to you and so in terms of the
player experience what's what were some
of those pillars of what's important to
you guys with horizon zero dawn well
there's a couple of aspects first of all
basically exploration maybe this is a
large world if there's a lot of
mysteries in it there's a little story
to tell so we want the player to go out
there and find a string for interesting
places see a portal hole Rises and go
there and find an adventure there that's
really important for us but of course
it's also a combat game it is an open
world action-adventure and that
excellent part is really important to us
so as you go out there baby there's lots
of activities to do and lots of
creatures to fight and also lots of
humans to finals course as well but
there were a couple of big themes
obviously that are major pillars for us
it is the the nature versus the advanced
technology that is a big one it is that
David versus Goliath feeling of the
primitive hunter forces these giant
robotic machines so these are a couple
of these kind of tensions that we've
been playing with that are very key to
this game yeah and we see that in the
loadout of the you know the different
sort of explosive arrows the rope arrows
that the different ways that you have in
combat to take on a boss and I think
that what was particularly inspiring
about that particular fight here is it's
not just shoot the big thing until the
big thing you know until the damage bar
goes all the way down it's not just
shooted at the one weak point I've one
or two times until it falls down there's
more going on there's more challenge
there's more dynamics there and I and a
boy is she's not just a brutish hunter
that likes to kill things for killing
sake she's very respectful she's a very
curious character she's in a way a
champion of life so she does what she
needs to do
and there's that yeah that philosophy
that you know many associate with sort
of Native American tribes having that
respect for nature and do you guys sort
of draw on any particular problems of
history or of human civilization now and
in the past to sort of inspire you any
touchstones in particular how as part of
the research we looked at every single
tribe that ever existed and read their
stories and Native Americans tribes are
part of it as well but also Mongolian
tribes or African tribes may be it is
looking begging how humanity sort of
lives in its most primeval form which is
not a confirmation that all of these
tribes are in Reverse just to clarify
well yeah I mean it was you even early
on you know sort of the the trail you're
getting a look at a very diverse kind of
humanity you know and I think that
that's one of the powerful things in
terms of imagining a new future what
kind of diversity do you have there what
kind of societies have come up you know
given that it's basically sort of the
world has gone through a millennia of
upheaval and human shifting and nature
of talking about these tribes these
tribes they have never known a world
without these machines in it so the old
once that's that's us right so the way
they deal with the machines is very
different
some hunt them down some might do other
find other ways of dealing with them
they might find a way to make him
friendlier they might you know a lot of
different ways of dealing with them sure
Daisy identifies distinguish is the
difference between the try between the
tribes they're on the philosophy as how
they take on the world I mean it's easy
to imagine animal husbandry developing
you know with the grazing population for
example and of course every tribe has
their own story of their origin maybe
how they came to be what the machines
are doing none of all of these stories
are correct of course maybe there's lots
of mythology and legend there as well
well horizon zero dawn a world full of
stories and at this point a lot of
mysteries that I personally am so so
eager to explore gentlemen thank you so
much for coming on and taking the time
to talk about a new game horizon thank
you
zero dawn it's looking fantastic folks I
hope you're as excited as I am because
I'm really excited
you